on July 26 1971 the Apollo 15 space
module touched down on the moon and
astronauts emerged with a new vehicle
the lunar rover they took it for a test
drive it handled well on the rough
surface of the Moon so they could
Venture further from The Landing site
and really explore
[Music]
the lunar rover was no ordinary
four-wheeler millions of dollars of
research went into this one horsepower
wonder which became known as the moon
buggy
today Craftsmen build replicas for Space
Museums and to use as movie props
the team starts with the substantial
suspension system designed to smooth the
ride over the moon's Rocky Terrain
then they install a steering plate at
the front
they attach actuators which are
mechanisms that assist in steering
they connect the actuator Drive bars to
the steering plate
[Music]
together the steering plate and
actuators give the lunar rover an
incredibly tight turning radius of just
over three meters
they screw support brackets for the
actuators to the corners of the chassis
then they connect the actuators to them
[Music]
they use steel and aluminum bolts and
parts
however on the original moon buggy many
parts were made of Titanium because it
lightened the load carried into space
titanium is expensive and unnecessary
for this replica
the fenders are next they are extra
large to protect astronauts from lunar
dust kicked up by the Rover
they insert a locking mechanism in a
slit at the end of the drive shaft
and Slide the wheel hub onto the shaft
they turn the Hub to lock it in place
they are now ready for the wheels in the
atmospheric vacuum of the Moon Airfield
rubber tires were out of the question so
the original Rover had wire mesh tires
to mimic the look they've wrapped a wire
lattice around rubber tires
the team secures the wheel to the hub
with a plastic and aluminum cap that's
equipped with locking pins
[Music]
they give it a spin and install the
other three wheels
[Music]
next a technician assembles the
instrument panel
he inserts various switches and gauges
into their slots
[Music]
including this system reset switch
it's used to bring the displays back to
zero prior to an expedition
[Music]
he closes a two-piece collar around the
bottom of the switch
[Music]
he locks it in place with a top cap
he then flips the panel around and
tightens the nut on the back part of the
switch
with the system reset switch now snug to
the board the instrument panel is
complete
he places it in the housing
he installs metal bars around the
switches to keep them from being
accidentally tripped
[Music]
he assembles the steering handle which
is a t-shaped joystick next to the
instrument panel
they now transfer the steering and
instrument panel assembly to the vehicle
[Music]
they fasten the actuator switches to the
steering housing
[Music]
and then clip the wiring harness to the
floor of the lunar rover
they cover the bottom of the Rover with
flame resistant material
[Music]
they lower the electrical control panel
and Battery into the chassis and connect
them
the original Rover had two small
batteries but the mechanics of this
replica have had an update
the production of this lunar rover
replica continues with the fabrication
of a brake disc
the technician carefully measures the
dimensions and draws them onto a sheet
of plastic covered aluminum
[Music]
he drills a large hole for the main
drive shaft and four screw holes
he then cuts out the disc following the
penciled lines
he Smooths the rough edges using a fine
grit abrasive belt
[Music]
he Sands off the plastic liner and
abrades the aluminum surface to a satiny
Sheen
[Music]
the brake disc is now ready for assembly
to the lunar rover
[Music]
he attaches it to the main drive shaft
and lowers the assembly into the vehicle
[Music]
he bolts the disc to the chassis where
it will serve as a friction surface for
the brake pads which he installs next
[Music]
he connects it to a spring mechanism for
engaging the disc brake
he tests the drive shaft and disc brake
and confirms that they're both in
working order
[Music]
he Loops a roller chain around the
sprocket gear for the rear wheel drive
and the teeth intermesh
he drives pins through the links to join
the ends closing the loop this drive
chain is powered by an electric motor
it's another mechanical modification on
the original Rover there was a small
motor for every wheel and no drive chain
the lawn chair-like seats are next
[Music]
they cover the shocks and battery at the
front with an aluminum Hood
[Music]
they also install a cover over the
mechanics at the back it doubles as a
rack for tools for geological excavation
[Music]
they attach the umbrella antenna to the
Rover it was used to beam pictures and
data to Earth
next an aluminum cylinder spins in a
lathe as cutting tools transform it into
a mount for a film camera
[Music]
they also machine a bracket for a
Communications antenna
[Music]
quite a transformation
using the bracket a member of the crew
now erects the communications antenna
he then installs the mount for the film
camera
[Music]
next using a Shear press he lops off a
piece of an aluminum sheet
[Music]
he switches to a hand tool and cuts out
a geometric shape with flaps
[Music]
he folds up the flaps using a brake
press creating a box to cover the main
battery
[Music]
after the seams have been welded he
wraps the cover in mylar which is a
strong plastic film
the wrap is an extra layer of protection
against wind-borne particles known as
micrometeoroids
they also wrap the camera and other
parts of the Rover with mylar
this replica of the Apollo lunar rover
is complete and ready to expand the
universe of the curious
[Music]